sponsored by PlayStation VR
hey friends I'm buddy Hutton if you see
my work on GameSpot you know that I'm a
big Justin roiland fan so obviously it
was excited to get to plate Rover saves
the universe this was my first video
game breakdown ever and not being able
to rewind really change the way that I
work I think this was the funniest video
game that I've ever played and maybe the
funniest one ever made but we can do
battle about that in the comments later
now let's break down trover saves the
universe for PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation VR controller saves the
universe you weren't actually trover but
you do take part in the whole saving the
universe thing you plays an unnamed
Shero peon who's working with trover
only because he's on assignment from his
boss at the important cosmic jobs office
beings from Planet churro P are fused to
are possibly born sitting in an armchair
holding what looks remarkably like a
PlayStation DualShock for you connect
this controller to trover who is an eye
hole monster by simply taking one of the
power babies out of his eye holes and
plugging it in giving you dominion over
Traverse body but his mind and voice
belonged to Justin roiland a fact he
will be reminded of often just me the
voice actor talking it's just one voice
but we put a special effect to make it
sound like three characters talking at
once you know what I've done trover
saves the universe is a PlayStation VR
game you can look down in VR to see your
useless little churro peon legs kicking
around or lean to check behind things to
find collectibles which are those power
babies I mentioned before as you play
through the game both you and trove or
get ability and movement upgrades
allowing you to access more areas to
solve more puzzles and find more
freaking power babies so you know power
babies are like super important man
because the red ones give me health but
like the green ones I'm trying to save
those because they're an endangered
species and if you collect them that'll
really put some skin in the game for me
you know it's like tipping an uber
driver plus they get me really high okay
so this is an Easter Egg video and I'll
get to them in a second but I want to
mention something first this game is
different than anything I've played
before it feels like Justin is just
making it all up on the spot and I found
out that's because he kind of is
launched games
formerly squanch tendo was created when
Justin paired up with Tonia Watson
former EP at Epic Games the company they
built makes games that are funny by
making the funny first and then building
the game around it improv style which is
a pretty new concept in games
the vo and the game is made up by Justin
from a bulleted list of story beats he
would just go into the booth and make
things funny they even made new dev
tools to help the creative process and
I'm used to well a comes before B B
comes before C you know and this is kind
of the Waker and with accounting and
with all this stuff that we're currently
making you know we've completely reset
that paradigm they said we'll wait like
let's rethink this and because they
didn't want repeated dialogue they put
20 hours of audio into an 8 hour game
you're gonna find things that I didn't
find in this video because there's
different ways to trigger a different
dialogue for example there are three
different outcomes to this altercation
with an old churro pian you can leave
them alone
beat him to silence or kill them
depending on what you do you'll have a
different experience at the end of the
game a lot of the Easter eggs come from
waiting around in a scene after you
receive instructions just to hear what
the vo develops into as Justin tries to
make himself laugh and you'll laugh too
unless you're a soulless eyehole monster
[Music]
it's the first game I've ever played
that's gotten more entertaining as you
just sit there doing nothing if you have
as much trouble sitting still as I do
there's a trash can basketball hoop that
you can use your PS VR headset to aim
with you're gonna get a lot of use out
of it while you're hanging out your
telepods listening to bathtub guy talk
about his relationship with his mother
but my mother always says bathtub guy
shut up about real estate with the
shared artisan writing staff and justin
roiland and self they're gonna be
moments in this game that you feel the
characters and scenes are direct
references to those familiar shows but
I've been assured that none of that is
on purpose
it's just Justin being purely creative
and what tends to come out is all the
sphincters farts and testicle trees that
we all love so much okay so let's start
with what is always at the forefront of
my mind
Rick and Morty your dogs who are
kidnapped by glork on at the beginning
of the game look a lot like snowball
from Rick and Morty season one
that's because snowball is based on one
of Justin's actual dogs who are named
Jerry and pup pup just look at them in
glorious VR you feel like you can almost
shove them right into your eye holes the
first world that you ensure overhead too
is called Schliemann world
the word fleen is used a few times in
Rick and Morty it's on the I dick Schley
knees bumper sticker on Rick ship and is
one of the key ingredients in plumpest
manufacturer the testicle trees that
their actual name I checked on
Schliemann are reminiscent of the mega
trees and that they have what looks to
be a scrotum with VR you can really get
in and inspect the scrotum too there are
boxes of science [ __ ] that remind me of
the box of time-travel stuff on the
shelves and Rick's garage flesh world
looks like Anatomy Park that was
Cronenberg drovers boss at the important
cosmic jobs office has a mounted worm
head that looks like a green gibble
snake from the were leaderly conspiracy
with green protrusions coming out of its
mouth actually trailers boss is like a
mash up of Rick and zeep zan Thorpe
wearing a more elaborate Council of Rick
neck triangle with green protrusions on
his head and they added a weird hole in
his forehead possibly for a power baby
maybe I went too deep here Justin
roiland plays a lot of video games so
there are a ton of references in the vo
to other games as you move blocks in the
level shroom eeeh using the psvr head
control some enemies start heckling you
with Minecraft jokes yeah what are they
stupid are they gonna build a fort
they'll never build a fort as coolers
are for there are really deep cuts like
gore Khan calling the power generating
equipment in his base a pylon like from
Starcraft the Konami code up up down
down be a start is mentioned as well as
references that you can find to Donkey
Kong banjo kazooie and even dragon's
lair
and flair from 1985 on flesh world there
are bugs that look like the Piranha
Plants from mario brothers while they
are in the ground you can pop them up
into the air catch them and shoot them
at targets in VR it feels like you have
freaking telepathy on slimming world
there are green sewer pipes that look
like warp tubes from Mario Brothers
there are more movie references than I
could keep track of in just so many
mentions of general pop culture one of
my favorites included a prisoner who
begins a monologue that sounds like a
quote from Shawshank Redemption but
quickly turns into him fetishizing poop
go make some your butt pudding and flush
that baby brown down to Andy town
because daddy gotta eat
Andy town is me I'm in ok this guy on
churro Pia is the inventor of black
holes and looks a lot like Stephen
Hawking glork ons bass has a massive
shield around it like an Empire Strikes
Back
not to mention that trover is using a
lightsaber lastly a few things about the
game cover on the back cover there are
war badges for made-up things like the
flip flop award and best looper now for
the biggest easter egg of all this is a
hand-drawn concept of trover done by
justin roiland which will be on the
inside cover of the game on the other
fold you can see behind the telepods
what looks like someone crawling into a
cave this is what justin roiland drew
when asked what Gloor con would look
like when sticking his head into the
telepods gore con is a large hairless
naked purple chicken what justin drew
looks like a human baby with hair and
clothes on what was he trying to draw
this made people at squanch so delighted
or confused that without Justin's
knowledge they hid this image throughout
the game some of them even got tattoos
of it I Squatch it and I'm ready to get
back on that horse as I mentioned before
you're gonna find your own Easter eggs
and hear dialogue that I didn't because
there's a huge pool of it that I
couldn't have possibly triggered all of
so let us know what you find in the
comments I didn't find all the power
babies maybe because I was too true to
my churro peon role and staying firmly
planted in my armchair and not using my
psvr to look behind every last testicle
tree lastly squash games is planning to
expand the game with a steady stream a
free DLC developed after they
lease it so there will be more poop
jokes to come starting on May 31st you
can get a bundle with the PlayStation VR
headset in camera along with game
vouchers for five nights at Freddy's
Help Wanted VR and trover saves the
universe all for $299.99 MSRP you should
go get it thank you so much for watching
I love you go play your stupid dumb game
beat us stupid idiots
sponsored by PlayStation VR